all right up next is going to be a new
Erica in nuttin Rika Marika there we go
in Fort Lauderdale Hina Rika how are you
hi babe thank you for taking my call
sure what's up I am a new listener to
you I just pumped in listening to you
for about two weeks now and I have read
you're on Total Money Makeover book and
I'm completely on like I'm hyped to get
my stuff out of it and I'm going to do
what it takes you out of it um my my
issues I'm having right now though is
like I am currently already behind on my
bills I'm already working two jobs
that's very the second job a couple
months ago and now I'm trying to get
like a third from like side hustle to
kind of even beef up my my um income
some more but I'm already behind and I
in trying to follow your principle like
I have a lease that I you said I need to
get out of that I got to see the four
thousand dollars to get out of that I
have a payday advance I need to get rid
of that but then it's kind of like I pay
that back then I'm like even like I'm
going to tougher bind and I'm already
behind so I'm trying to get a baby step
number one all right like yeah you're
not you're not even up to ground level
yet okay so let's just start
establishing some priorities all right
here we go are you ready yes okay but
the first thing you buy is food and
every month the second thing you do is
you pay your utilities lights and water
mm-hmm don't do anything that you've
done those two things okay
the third thing you do is you pay your
rent okay now what is your income per
month total from all of these sources my
income right now is 50,000 okay
phenomenal and how much is your rent
I'm Nora jizz about 1,400 1,400 okay and
are you single I am single I'm a single
mom
okay so we're going to eat keep the
lights and water on pay the house
payment a lot of money left after you've
done those things
okay next goal is to be current on your
bills what else are you behind on my
credit card is big how far behind are
you on your credit card
nice okay and how much is is the payment
oh my gosh my total credit card you know
you're breaking up when you need to walk
into a different room sorry that's all I
was saying okay can you hear me yes
ma'am
okay I was saying that my total credit
card payments are about $800 a month
okay and you're two months behind on
that correct okay how much is your car
payment my car payment is six hundred
good Louise it's a lease and I don't
have to get out of it I know and I'm but
I gotta save the $4,000 $4,000 upside
down correct and your credit is
destroyed correct
okay all right good and how much do you
owe the payday lender five I asked today
I paid them back but I I really want to
take it back no don't take it back never
walk in there again next time you drop
by there I want you to visualize it says
across the front of it stupid people
come here
that's what cuz that's what it is
alright and you're not and you're not
stupid people anymore so you can't go
there anymore stupid people come in here
that's what their sign says across the
front okay mm-hmm does your knit you're
gonna be broke your whole life if you
keep messing with HR yeah I know okay I
know you're living desperate too
desperate now let's calm down in it all
right
I can pay your house payment and your
car payment is your car current my car
is Korea I have a touch car oh good you
pay your car current you keep your house
payment current you eat you keep your
lights on you keep gas in the car now I
can breathe and there's still room in
this budget oh my god I haven't paid the
credit cards yet all you did was eat
keep the lights on and pay out a $1,400
car our house payment the $600 car
payment that's $2,000 plus lights and
water you can do that mm-hmm
okay you breathin with me now the
problem is you're letting these other
things Trump the things that are more
important and I'm trying to really set
solid food shelter transportation and
utilities are your baseline you do that
before you do anything and then
emotionally the rest of it is just a all
you got then is just the credit card
debt am I missing something
no what sittin on that but that's
deferred right now cuz I am in school
try to increase my income good okay so
then the only thing you need to do is to
start working towards getting current
with some of the credit cards okay the
problem is they call and yell at you and
they reset your priorities if you let
them but don't well they're the bottom
of the food chain and if they call and
yell that's the one you don't pay them
to bite your ankle okay we're going to
get back to them I want you to get
current but you've got to keep the
fright things first if you'll keep food
shelter lights and transportation paid
you'll get current on the credit cards
we'll begin to pay those down and then
we'll get you out of that lease with the
four thousand dollars saved up and
you're going to be fine you're going to
make it I want you to go through our
class Financial Peace University as my
gift because you're ready to turn your
life around and we will hold your hand
and walk with you while you do it but
you can do this
hold on Kelly I'll pick up we'll get you
signed up this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope
you're enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better
Dave Ramsey channel Motel Emma says that
I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you